هذه الحسناء تهمت بالتسبب في ازمه لنجوم
بالدوري الانجليزي تخيلوا ان احدهم تناول
اقراصا منومه للهروب منها والسبب مطاردتها
لهم والتي انتهت بها الى المحاكمه لكن
لماذا طردتهم التيك توك او صاحبه الواحد
والعشرين عاما واحدى اشهر نجوم السوشيال
ميديا في بريطانيا اعترفت امام المحكمه
بمطاردتها لبعض نجوم الدوري الانجليزي
بعدما قطع لاعب نادي تشيلسي ميسون ماوت في
عام 2020 علاقته بها والتي استمرت لسته
اشهر وبحسب المدعي العام استخدمت ميليسا
واحدا وعشرين رقما لامطار موت بالرسائل
وكلما كان يحضرها كانت تلاحقه من رقم جديد
ما اثر سلبا على ادائه بحسب اقواله لدرجه
انه كان قلقا من ان يكون لديها هوس او
تعلق به ولم يكن يعرف ماذا يمكن ان تفعل
نفس المطارده قامت بها مع زميله السابق
بالجليمون الذي كان يتناول الحبوب المنومه
ليهرب من مضايقاتها والسيناريو نفسه وقع
مع لاعب اخر فيما تم الافراج عن ميليسا
بكفاله في انتظار انتهاء التحقيقات حول
مصيرها